all right there were a bunch of new
concepts here let's start with an it in
it creates a repository and doesn't
directly relate to any of the other
concepts currently on the map so it
seems pretty straightforward we just
want to connect it to repository since
it does something with repository it
creates it this is an operates on
connection there's only one spot that
makes sense for an it given this the
rest of these are a little bit trickier
let's think about the staging area you
put things into the staging area before
you make it commit so it's pretty
related to the concept of a commit get
ad and get status both work on the
staging area to help you make the
commits both of these are going to have
operates on connections to the staging
area the status also shows you what's in
your working directory so it'll have an
operates on connection to working
directory as well so this gives us
enough information to go ahead and fill
in all of these